[Applaudissements]
balzeau farba dit ne touchait pas à
notre corps 200 manifestations dans
cinquante états américains
le mot d'ordre a été entendue partout à
travers le pays à houston au texas à
chicago san francisco new york
atlanta
les groupes pour le droit à l'avortement
sont mobilisés depuis que la fuite d'un
document de la cour suprême publié sur
le site d'information politico révélé
que l'institution judiciaire accorderait
le droit aux états d'autoriser ou
d'interdire le droit à l'avortement
nous n'irons pas en arrière ce camp des
manifestants à washington
[Applaudissements]
c'est un retour en arrière dit elle je
suis de la génération millénaire 1
retourne 50 ans en arrière c'est la
génération de ma mère j'ai une fille de
9 mois et je veux qu'elle puisse décider
pour son avion
sud où
marlène bennett quant à elle à une
impression de déjà-vu elle luttait dans
les années 70 pour l'accès à
l'avortement
elie
basse et j'ai 83 ans dit elle je viens
du texas nous étions venus en autobus à
washington dans les années 70 je doute
que les femmes bénéficieront un jour de
l'égalité pour les manifestants et si ce
n'est pas seulement l'accès à
l'avortement qui est en jeu mais la
santé des femmes que si jamais
l'avortement en demeure illégale aux
états unis elles vont continuer à se
faire avorter les lanières clandestine
et là c'est leur santé qui rangeait
oui
[Applaudissements]
l'administration baden a tenté de
légiférer sur la question de
l'avortement la chambre des
représentants a voté à l'automne dernier
une loi garantissant l'accès à
l'avortement dans tout le pays mais ce
texte est toujours bloqué au sénat 51
sénateurs s'y sont opposés et 49
démocrates ont appuyé les démocrates
espèrent que la question de l'avortement
sera l'enjeu principal des élections de
mi mandat en novembre prochain la
décision finale de la cour suprême est
prévue à la fin du mois de juin au début
du mois de juillet il s'est évadé
guerguisse radio-canada washington